[Musique]
elle doit du vin carrier est un artiste
contemporain haïtien avec sa famille il
a dû fuir son pays durant la dictature
duvaliériste déracinés carrière duval
air et à porto rico à paris et au canada
avant d'atterrir à petit haïti à miami
ils n'osent pas retourner en haïti
cette oeuvre exprime sa quête
identitaire une recherche de ses racines
qu'il explique à cette passionnée d'art
[Musique]
c'est bon c'est mon autoportrait
c'est mon autoportrait attaquable dire
c'est parce que je suis complètement
déracinés et que je suis en train de
bouger
je cherche merci mais voilà est sympa
mais je me tiens droit parce que j'ai
fait de maintenir cette indignité
lassé de recherche haïti est au coeur de
toutes les oeuvres de duval carrié
voici le collier dédiée à la grande
déesse de voodoo haïtien est jolie
freida les fleurs géantes les médaillons
et les images de ces prétendants sont
fabriqués en résine
en effet les symboles voodoo occupe une
grande place dans son travail
mais duval carrié n'est pas initié jeu
puis pas ils me permettent de dire que
oui vous du yéyé et que je suis très
content le vaudou et tout ça ils ont les
macoutes c'était quoi
c'était une façon de donner de
contourner le veau le vaudou pour
maintenir le peuple haïtien dans une
dans la terreur
donc il faut que je puisse analyser tout
cela aussi oui ça c'est bon côté ce à
ses côtés est fabuleux et fantastique et
tout ça mais en même temps ça s'écoute
est assez sombre et et et
horrible même à travers la famille
duvalier nous avons vécu des trois
décennies de baron samedi et de sang et
tout ça donc il faut que je puisse en
parler moi
à 72 ans livreur et clank antys
trinidadien cherche toujours un monde
parfait dans ses oeuvres aussi bien
qu'aux scènes même de l'humanité
son tableau la forêt en flammes inspiré
par sa foi africaine larrieu robin est
un retour un monde innocence
ils vont être longues estime que les
hommes et les femmes se sont égarés dans
cette civilisation moderne il y a
quelque chose de profond quelque chose
d'essentiel chez la femme langage de
femmes qu'elles refusent d'écouter et
cherche à l'extérieur d'elle-même la
vérité au lieu de chercher au fond
d'elle-même elle veut ressembler à des
hommes et se comporter en homme ensuite
le pauvre homme cherche une femme et il
trouve qu'elle limite mieux qu'il est
vraiment il devient comme une femme et
il veut être les gars de la femme quelle
catastrophe
sept autres grands tableaux s'inspirent
de la confusion qui règne dans le monde
les clous ne représentent les dirigeants
et les multinationales clank utilisent
les couleurs vives pour attirer
l'attention sur la complaisance du
peuple veut travaillons pour ce monde
tel qu'il est et c'est nous voyons un
système en train de s'effondrer mais
nous agissons comme si nous vivons tout
simplement dans une époque
d'effondrement tél nous n'avons pas la
fois nécessaire en nous pour changer
tout cela
ni faire en sorte que le navire qui
représente ce monde change de bord
on recrée et ce à sa personne c'est à
dire ne pas se contenter de ce qu'on
nous donne qui peut vraiment se chercher
pour en fait contre lui même
vraiment
vraiment tous ses skis mais c'est
vraiment aller au fond deux pas et
et qu'il a parlé aussi de créer un
nouveau langage et
pour un artiste c'est le but d'un
artiste crée un nouveau modèle en fait
n'en parle à toutes les générations
edouard duval carrié et l'iran et clank
font partie des références de l'art
moderne de la caraïbe à
[Musique]